la mise en scène est soigneusement
planifié un point de presse devant la
cour suprême du canada mais que ousmane
sourire et affiche en main les militants
anti avortement sont revigorés à la
veille de leur grande marche annuelle à
ottawa et là on a vu une brèche
exactement avec l'arrêt rovers wade qui
a été renversée ou qui va être renversé
on l'espère ils veulent surfer sur une
possible annulation du droit à
l'avortement par la cour suprême des
etats unis une décision croit-il qui
pourrait redonner un souffle à leur
mouvement au canada sa part avoir des
retentissements culturelle sur toute la
planète spécialement au canada on est
juste à côté des états unis ou même
moment le gouvernement trudeau en
profite aussi pour se positionner
l'évolution de la situation aux
etats-unis nous rappelle à toutes et à
tous que nous ne pouvons pas tenir ses
droits et libertés pour acquis les
libéraux annonce le financement de
nouveaux projets pour améliorer l'accès
à l'avortement au pays le premier
ministre va plus loin justin trudeau
n'écarte pas la possibilité de légiférer
pour protéger le droit à l'avortement
nous on veut comprendre ce qui et
comment on va mieux protéger les droits
des femmes pour les années à venir je
pense que c'est quelque chose sur
lesquels la vaste majorité des canadiens
sont allées bien que la cour suprême du
canada et décriminaliser l'avortement à
la fin des années 80 où que gouvernement
n'a légiféré pour encadrer cette
pratique ou en garantir l'accès mais
selon certains juristes un cadre
législatif pourrait avoir l'effet
inverse et restreindre l'accès parce
qu'il faudrait y lit avec l'urd et
balises le gouvernement en est conscient
elle est plus loin selon certains
pourrait ne pas être une bonne idée si
on parle évidemment le d'assurer et de
garantir
l'accès à l'avortement non je revient
sous les projecteurs en pleine course à
la direction du parti conservateur des
députés accusés libéraux de raviver le
débat pour des raisons partisanes ce
trousseau face la voix cassée justin
trudeau les libéraux qui ramène des
débats sont d'abord de notre côté
reste que les prises de position de
leslie l'ouest sont remarquées elle est
la seule candidate anti avortement de la
course est conservatrice et cela lui
vaut déjà des appuis triple saut
le gouvernement trudeau se défend
d'utiliser ce qui se passe aux
etats-unis pour marquer des points ici
au canada mais les libéraux savent très
bien que l'avortement est un terrain
miné pour les conservateurs et ils ont
choisi le jour de leur premier débat
officiel de la course à la chefferie
pour ramener le sujet à l'avant scène
ici louis blouin radio canada